well what's the girliest thing you've
done with your girls because we have a
lot of like they called girl daddies I
think that's what kind of jokes we've
had a lot of them on their show and I
love that I'm involved in all levels of
what goes on but I'm under a lot of
pressure to have my toenails and
fingernails painted a lot of pressure
yeah honestly I've seen my husband paint
my daughter's toenails our eldest when
we first got together and he does a
really good job like better than me I
found out that I'm not bad at braiding
hair recently he's gonna do yeah I don't
know he had horses growing up so maybe
because he did that what their main I
don't know yeah yeah I can braid I
played sports so I'm really bad at the
hair I'm good at I'm good at the
pretending so like the tea parties and
like when I'm cast as sometimes I'm you
know I'm stepmother or I'm good at the
pretending stuff yeah yeah yeah I'm not
good at the hair Brady's yeah just one
just a little girl a little girl hello
she is she'll be three three awesome
graduation a
April 23rd that's right a day before
mine get out of here Taurus Taurus man
he'll you let me know what I'm in for
we're sweet until we're not I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this